bonsoir de masse gordon de publier aux
éditions nouveau monde histoire secrète
du mossad le mossad ce sont les services
secrets israéliens
alors nous parlions avec pierre
lellouche de l'accession de l'iran à la
puissance nucléaire et vous raconter
comment israël a obtenu la sienne grâce
au mossad
et vous parlez d'un juif influents de la
communauté scientifique américaine qui
laisser partir les containers vers
israël alors ce qui s'est passé ce
scientifique américain juif américain
avait accès parce qu'ils étaient
industriels à des matériaux nucléaires
qui étaient transportés par la compagnie
aérienne el al jusqu'à tel-aviv et c'est
là que va commencer la construction de
la bombe israélienne choix qui a 200
bombes nucléaires israéliennes à ce jour
alors aujourd'hui au proche orient nous
avons affaire à une crise monumentale
parce que vous avez à le hamas au
pouvoir
j'ai écouté ce qu'a dit natanyahou ce
soir il y faut être prêt à se défendre
il ya quelques jours je me suis
entretenu avec des personnes importantes
at elle admis au ministère de défense et
kaya qui m'ont dit que il serait à deux
doigts d'une attaque préventive en
faisant intervenir là encore des sous
marins nucléaires qui sont dans dans le
golfe d'aden
il y a tout un escadron de bombardier
qui seront équipés de missiles et sont
prêts allez allez au combat et je crois
que après l'élection palestinienne y
risque d'y avoir une frappe à ce que
l'élite rennes ne n'est pas prête à se
laisser menacé par l'arrivée du hamas il
me semble que
l'iran est bien plus dangereux que
l'irak ne l'a jamais été ça c'est quand
même s'il faut se rappeler le message
qui ressort de mon lycée qu'il faut et
savoir que nous avons probablement à
faire laver la crise la plus grave du
moyen-orient au sujet de l'irak vous
raconter que bush avait autorisé
l'assassinât de saddam hussein ce qui
était votre votre théorie en impliquant
le mossad et que l'opération tourner
autour de l'insatiable appétit sexuel de
saddam hussein il avait une maîtresse
qu'il dauger dans une villa des rives de
l'euphrate
mais malheureusement 13 s'est suicidé il
était prévu que le mossad s'empare de
saddam hussein dans sa maison de plaisir
aux bords de l'euphrate
est ce que vous pensez qu'il a été
impliqué dans la capture de saddam
hussein en irak après farewell en direct
les vidéos directement parce que ce qui
s'est passé c'est que la femme c'est
ahmed mais l'argent est différente et le
massage la retrouver ils ont tout
raconté aux amis intéressés la relation
entre le mossad et ses proches enfin je
crois que quand vous avez deux services
on peut pas été mon plus proche que ça
donc ils ont donné le renseignement qui
a permis aux forces spéciales
canadiennes de se rapprocher de takrit
des captures et sanary
alors vous raconter comment le mossad
avait prévu la tacc contre le world
trade center
quelque chose se préparait disait-il aux
américains quelque chose aussi violent
que la et et hiroshima et les américains
sont restés sourds pourquoi votre avis
ce qui est curieux c'est qu'il y avait
le syndrome des pierres qui crient au
loup alors il y a effectivement eu des
révélations du mossad qui se sont
révélées inexactes alors là les
américains ont demandé des preuves
maladie l'attak est en préparation ne
peux pas vous dire elle aura lieu mais
ce sera pour bientôt et probablement
elle sera dirigée depuis l'europe
vous avez raison sur ce point mais par
contre il n'était pas en mesure
rien de pire que la 6è les tours
jumelles mais n'était pas loin de la
réalité alors il y a eu par la suite des
accusations selon laquelle il y avait
des agents du mossad qui surveillait
s'acquittant c'est quand il est élu on a
accusé n'importe quoi mais il n'ya tout
un mystère autour du rôle du mossad et
j'essayais de fêter cette question de la
manière la plus objective possible alors
toujours dans le domaine du terrorisme
vous abordez la traque des hauteurs de
munich dont steven spielberg parle dans
son film munich alors vous parlez vous
du fiasco de lillehammer ou un innocent
a été abattu par le mossad à la place de
ali hassan salameh
et cet innocent dont spielberg ne dit
pas un mot mais dont vous parlez vous
s'appelle à mettre debout chicchi et
c'est le frère de chico bouchikhi des
gipsy kings 5 royal il était serveur et
à lillehammer en suède dans un bistrot
il a été tué à la place d'un autre et
nous tenons parle pas dans son film quoi
les slops non c'est vrai beaucoup de
choses que le film fasse aussi lent ce
qui est regrettable sujet ce film qui
est par ailleurs un très bon film sur le
plan des victimes j c'est l'ancien
intérêts clergeau animaux sacs de riz
c'est dans le genre indiana jones est
très sympa mais sur le plan des faits
c'est complètement inexacte
alors c'est un thriller passionnant mais
très loin de la réalité et c'est
pourquoi d'ailleurs le mossad étaient
les furieux parce que ce qu'on y voit
n'a rien à voir avec la réalité et le
président du mossad à qu'elle a vu le
film il ya deux semaines il dit je
croyais pas que je perde nous aurait
fait un truc pareil parce que il ya un
compte des salades
la réalité est bien plus passionnante
que la fiction moi j'ai vu les rapports
des personnes participaient à ces trades
à fiat and i like om qui faisait partie
des équipes de tueurs ce qu'ils ont fait
beaucoup plus passionnant la façon dont
lecture de munich alors si vous
intéresser à ce genre de choses ils ont
réussi à tuer les terroristes de manière
extraordinaire par exemple en faisant
sauter la tête du terrorisme dans sa
chambre à coucher
alors ça fait très peu affaissé
effrayant mais enfin c'est comme un tour
de force il faut pas faire les marioles
avec le mot salle ils sont très très
dangereux si vous les terroristes
alors dans votre livre vous parlez du
mossad évidemment et puis vous fait des
révélations qui n'engage que vous je
tiens à le préciser quand même parce que
c'est assez énorme vous dit par exemple
que ali agça le turc qui a tenté
d'assassiner le pape jean paul ii ne
travaillait pas pour lequel j'ai
bestiaire pas pour les russes n'ont plus
pour les bulgares contrairement à ce
qu'on a pu raconter mais qu'en fait il
été manipulé par l'ayatollah khomeiny et
qu'en fait l'assassinât du pape aurait
été finalement le signal inaugurale du
jihad contre l'occident
c'est exactement cela
vous avez dit exactement en quelques
mots exactement la réalité
moi j'ai vu la famille de rallier axa
dans le nord de la turquie d'épouser a
bien voulu me parler et elle m'a raconté
toute la vie de son mari sa formation et
recrutement hiver et puis il m'a dit
elle m'a dit que effectivement le pape
l'avait pardonné quelques années plus
tard mais elle m'a également parlé de sa
relation avec l'iran qui est dans le
livre vous dites que le pape est allé
voir rallier axa dans sa prison pour
vérifier les informations du mossad et
ce quoi c'est l'ayatollah khomeiny qui
aurait commandité son assassinat à
cesser votre version des terres
si effectivement le pape après les cuit
quatre journalistes j'ai eu la chance
d'être l'un d'entre eux vont s'est rendu
dans cette prison le jour de noël et le
saint père a fait s'est agenouillé
devant la cellule et à écouter ce que la
cave et attire et puis ensuite
c'est la suite le secrétaire du pape qui
me disent qu'il avait dit alors il ya un
truc incroyable dans votre bouquin c'est
au sujet de la mort de lady di et de
dodi al fayed
je vous racontais que henri paul en fait
le chauffeur était dans cet état là
parce qu'ils étaient soumis à des
pressions du mossad pour qu'ils
travaillent avec eux absolument
c'est pour ça dit vous qui prenait des
tranquillisants qui buvaient un peu trop
parce que le mossad savait des choses
sur lui qui a compati donner les infos
paparazzi sur les clients du ritz et qui
savaient pas quoi faire ils étaient un
peu pris au piège il faut être analysé
un peu ce qui s'est passé à l'époque le
mossad pensait que le rythme était
utilisé par des trafiquants d'armes dont
john hutton et keane qui était l'ancien
ministre conservateur
il s'inquiétait de ce qui se passait il
voulait qu'il y ait quelqu'un
l'intérieur de l'hôtel
une chose qui pourrait utiliser il y
avait personne voulait quelqu'un qui
soit suffisamment bien placé qui taxé à
tout les gens dits puisse un peu tout
surveiller et dans une réunion tel aviv
ils ont décidé que la personne idéale
ce serait le chef adjoint de la sécurité
qui n'était autre que en bis paul ii
qu'ils ont envoyé une équipe à paris
pour essayer de de le convaincre est
alors à l'époque henri paul avait
effectivement des contacts avec les
services du renseignement français
il travaille est pourquoi pour les
services français du contre espionnage
est évidemment lorsqu'on est sous
pression du mossad une pression très
lourdes on la sent en fait il avait
arrêté de bois s'était rendu compte
l'alcoolisme est un problème et c'est
eux qui l'ont reconduit à l'alcool mais
il ne s'intéressait pas à toutes ces
affaires se dire que
histoire que les dida et allait épouser
dodi al fayed riz que ces histoires
n'intéressait pas tellement mossad tas
d'autres services de renseignement mais
ce qui était intéressant par contre est
à trouver dans retrouver il y avait en
fait quatre services du renseignement
entourent de autour d'eux les dida et et
de 10 juillet il y avait la cia et le
mossad
il y avait des services du renseignement
français quatre services renseignements
sur diana et pour des raisons
différentes
toujours est il que la msa américaines
annie dyer qu'elle détenait 150 document
intercepté
concernant les dida et et de 10 et leur
linge décide mot pour mot pouvait pas
révéler cette information parce que il y
avait des questions de sûreté nationale
on se demande quel est le secret d'état
ils pouvaient y avait dedans mais enfin
ce qui est certain c'est que les dida se
préoccuper beaucoup la question des
mines antipersonnel il voulait il mettre
un terme elle avait d'ailleurs réussi à
convaincre le pen linton d'accompagner
alors les services de renseignements
anglais
voyez en elle quelqu'un un agent un peu
un peu dangereux sur cette histoire de
lady day de dial fayed
vous parlez dans votre bouquin de la
fiat uno blanche est aperçu dans le
souterrain vite qu'elle appartenait à un
paparazzi qui s'attelle james tant dans
son camp que blizzard on a retrouvé mort
brûlé dans sa voiture quelques mois plus
tard yes oui c'est vrai je ne sais pas
qui a mis le feu à sa voiture lui il
n'avait aucune raison de se suicider
déséquilibré il avait une scène argent
ici en fouillant sardaigne le lendemain
de la mort de lady oui c'est peut-être
pour toucher une somme d'argent en
échange de la voiture qu'il avait à ce
propos des hypothèses
enfin on l'a retrouvé mort dans sa
voiture ça c'est un autre mystère le
ministère les dida et de diva va durer
éternellement ça j'en suis certain et on
trouvera probablement jamais la solution
et je ne pense pas qu'elle enquête
britannique apportera des éléments de
réponse ils disent quoi les gens du
mossad quand ils lisent votre livre moi
j'ai passé deux ans et demi avec le
mossad travailler avec les agents du
mossad pas pour le mossad avec eux et
j'ai été très flatté ils m'ont invité
justement écrire ce livre ce qu'il
établira enfin je crois que c'est la
première fois que ça arrive que
quelqu'un entre en quelque sorte que
dans les rangs du mossad j'étais
directeur et un dirigeant et et j'ai
toujours beaucoup d'informations qui me
vient du mossad dans la version mise à
jour d'ailleurs du livre merci gordon
thomas histoire sera du mossad
ces deux éditions nouveau monde met la
pression